[Music]
who are you consulting with consistently
so that you're ready on day one I'm
speaking with myself number one because
I have a very good brain and I've said a
lot of things stabilizing
dangerous dangerous to the United States
dangerous to the world order if you will
here to explain Donald Trump's foreign
policy it's very easy to think of Donald
Trump is basically just saying
incoherent things when he talks about
the world in part because he often does
I would bomb the [ __ ] out of him the
issue though is that when you look
underneath all of them he he has a
worldview it's actually fairly clear for
Donald Trump his worldview is
transactional if you pay a lot of money
the US will help you if you don't pay a
lot of money the u.s. won't and really
it's that simple we are being ripped off
by everybody in there we're defending
other countries we are spending a
fortune doing it they have the bargain
of the century you need to take those
ideas seriously you need to engage with
them and say let's assume it is
President Trump let's look at the fact
that of all the things the president can
and cannot do foreign affairs foreign
policy is the area where here at the
freest hand he doesn't need Congress
when I heard that we were first going
into Iraq some very smart people told me
well we're actually going for the oil
and I said all right I get that I get
that there's nothing else I get it we
should take it and pay ourselves back
what are we doing Trump's idea of taking
the oil speaks to two things really
about the way that he views the world
the first one is that he sees basically
everything through the lens of what does
America get out of it
they pay us peanuts we're defending them
the second part is that Trump thinks of
good for the United States as
controlling stuff I
keep the oil keep the oil I mean we
could theoretically do it but Iraqis
wouldn't just give the oil to Americans
almost certainly it would fight a war
thousands of people would die it would
be an immensely complicated and
dangerous occupation dwarfing even the
2003 Iraq invasion for two years I've
been telling you take the oil hit the
oil bombed the oil
he thinks of things in this narrow
mercantilist what's good for me is when
I own stuff and sell it to you good
deals versus bad deals how are we gonna
take the oil how are we gonna do that
just we would leave a certain group
behind and you would take various
sections where they have the oil that
foreign policy is about managing your
relationship with other countries it's
not just about dominating them more to
the point we don't believe in
imperialism as a mode of governance in
the old days when we won a war to the
victor belongs the spoils the 28
countries have many of them aren't
paying their fair share when that
bothers me because we should be as we're
defending them and they should at least
be paying us what they're supposed to be
paying the issue is that NATO countries
promised to pay a certain amount of
their GDP towards defense other than the
u.s. almost no countries do it
so when Trump says they're not paying
their fair share he's right and NATO's
too expensive because we can't afford
this anymore and people are being
brought in for a free ride where it gets
dangerous is how he takes that to an
extreme and the extreme isn't therefore
nourish pay more it's therefore of
Russia invades will rethink whether we
come to the defense of NATO countries if
they don't make us whole they may have
to defend themselves in the NATO Charter
itself is one article in particular
called article 5 I don't think he knows
that our little fibers which says that
if you attack any NATO member the other
27 NATO countries have to come to its
defence and what Donald Trump is saying
is that that core mission of NATO that
only doesn't necessarily matter as much
but it's something that can be tossed
aside
NATO exists solely to deter Russia I
believe an easing of tensions and
improved relations with Russia from a
position of strength only is
possible absolutely possible refine
reporting this is his top strategic goal
in many ways they have spent 20 years
trying to weaken NATO and what Donald
Trump is saying is how could that do
he's not going into Ukraine okay just so
you understand he's not gonna go into
Ukraine you can mark it down you can put
it down you can take it any ways already
there what you have Donald Trump singing
opera Putin is astounding if he says
great things about me I'm gonna say
great things about him but Vladimir
Putin is - Donald Trump is a model of a
good leader a model of an effective
leader and a model of a popular leader
he's running this country and at least
he's a leader you know unlike what we
have in this country it's a very scary
model and any aspect of it that Vladimir
Putin does right now that dial Trump
would like to do wouldn't een in America
that we would not recognize well he does
have an 82 percent approval rating he's
also a guy who annex Crimea invaded
Ukraine supports Assad in Syria supports
Iran North Korea has nukes Japan is a
problem with that I mean they have a big
problem with it maybe they would in fact
be better off if they defend themselves
from less Korea maybe we would be better
off including with nukes yes including
with New South Korea with nukes South
Korea is right next door
instead of having South Korea Japan and
other allies develop their own nuclear
weapons programs they rely on our
nuclear forces if they're attacked they
don't have to worry about having their
own nuclear weapons because they know
for a fact that we will come to their
aid we extend our nuclear umbrella over
them what Trump is saying is that we
should withdraw that for decades one of
the bedrocks of American foreign policy
has been stopping nuclear proliferation
and specifically providing security to
some of our allies in exchange for at
least in part that they not seek nuclear
weapons that's been true under all
administration's Republican and Democrat
Donald Trump is promoting a new policy
with Trump you have him wanting to
withdraw the nuclear umbrella which
means that our allies Japan South Korea
are more likely to want to try to
develop their own nuclear weapons
because they feel threatened and they
don't have that guarantee anymore our
alliance with Japan
and the Republic of Korea it has
prevented the possibilities of a nuclear
escalation and conflict it would
completely destabilize the kind of
security structure that we've had in
East Asia for the last several decades
the person who made the statements
doesn't know much about foreign policy
or nuclear policy or the Korean
Peninsula or the world generally that
also means that we no longer really have
influence there so we can use the fact
that we are your security guarantee we
are your backers we have your back we
can use that to say okay but we need you
to do X Y & Z with this long hellish
election finally coming to close it's
been easy throughout and I think this is
a recent Donald Trump is done as well as
he has done to just laugh at his funnier
comments seem as a bit of a buffoon and
a clown and just not engaged with what
he says on any serious level and that's
a disservice that's dangerous especially
on foreign policy because that's where
President Trump would have the freest
hand to do what candidate Trump says he
would do
[Music]